[موسيقى]
لحد اللحظه اللي احنا فيها دي والعلم
بتاعنا لسه في مناطق مجهوله موحشه ما
فيهاش بشري واحد صحاري وجبال وجزر نائيه
وغابات ومحيطات واسعه ومساحات جليديه في
نهايه العالم مناطق ما حدش يقدر يسمع فيها
السيخ ابن يومين صعب جدا نلاقي فيها لمس
التكنولوجيا او توصلها اشاره تليفون واحده
حتى معظم الناس بيسموها مناطق غير ماهوله
وانه الماسك الرجل الحديدي زي ما كان
الاعلام الامريكي بيحب يوصفه بيسميها
مناطق ميته المناطق الميته دي مش المناطق
اللي ما فيهاش بشر بس في مناطق فيها
مليارات البشر وميته برضو لكن من ناحيه
التكنولوجيا علشان نفهم ده بصوا معي على
الخريطه دي دي خريطه بتوضح عدد الناس اللي
ما عندهمش انترنت ولا خدمات هاتفيه وفيهم
نسبه لا باس بها ما سمعتش عن الانترنت
اللي بتشوفوني منه دلوقتي ده اساسا كم
عددهم عشره مليون ميه مثلا لا حوالي 3
مليار انسان تقريبا 36% من سكان العالم ما
عندهمش انترنت نصهم تقريبا في الهند
والصيف وصعب توصل لهم كلهم الكابلات
البحريه اللي هي بتنقل لنا الانترنت زي ما
انتم شايفينها قدامكم علشان الكابلات دي
توصل للناس دي محتاجين وقت طويل وفلوس
ماهوله لحد وقت قريب جدا ما كانش في حل
شامل للمعضله دي لغايه ما لقينا ايلون
ماسك في 2015 طالع على مسرح مدينه سيات
الامريكيه قدام افراد شركته الشهيره سبيس
اكس علشان يعرفهم على مشروعه الجديد اللي
هيسيطر به على السمك
[موسيقى]
مجموعه من الاقمار الصناعيه الصغيره
هتديرها سبيس اكس وبتدور في المدار
المنخفض على ارتفاع ما بين 3600 ميل فوق
سطح البحر وده ارتفاع قليل جدا بالنسبه
للاقمار الصناعيه المع مثلا اللي بتدور
على ارتفاع 22 الف ميل على الاقل الى
الماسك بالمشروع ده كان عاوز يوصل
بالانترنت لكل مكان
قدرت في 2018 انه هيتكلف على الاقل 10
مليار دولار وهياخد عشر سنين علشان الاف
الاقمار تتصمم وتتصنع وتوصل لمكانها
وبالفعل عمل ده وهنعرف مع بعض بعد شويه
صغيرين انجازات سبيس اكس المدهشه في الكم
سنه اللي فاتوا لكن الاهم من الانجازات دي
وصلتنا للحظه الحاليه اللحظه اللي ادركت
فيها الصين مدى اللي ممكن تعمله
الاستخدامات العسكريه لشبك ستار لينك فيها
بعد ما شافت اللي عمله المشروع في
اوكرانيا ضد القوات الروسيه علشان كده
قررت بكين انها تعمل مشروع الاقمار
المضاده بتاعها مشروع غامض بيصلب حرف ايه
او جو وانك او شبكه الدوله وقررت كمان تحط
خطه عسكريه تحاول تجاوب بها على سؤال واحد
ازاي ممكن
الاقتصادي وبفكركم برضه ان كل حلقاتنا
اللي فاتت مترجمه للغه الانجليزيه فما
تنسوش تشاركوها مع اصحابكم الاجانب
تعرفوهم علينا انا اشرف ابراهيم المقبل
الاقتصادي
[موسيقى]
قبل ما ندخل في تفاصيل العركه دي عايز
اشكر شركه العالميه لرعايتها الحلقه دي
وهي شركه عندها خبره طويله في الاسواق
الماليه بحجم تداولات شهريه تجاوز التلاته
تليون دولار ليه بنصح بالتعامل مع علشان
اربع مميزات الاولى بعرف اسحب فلوسي فيها
بشكل فوري بدون تدخل بشري التانيه ان
التداولات بتتنفذ بسرعه التالته ان عملتهم
منخفضه مع رافعه ماليه تعتبر الاعلى
الرابعه انها مرخصه ومراقبه من هيئات
رقبيه تقدر تفتح حساب اسلامي لا محدود
وتبدا تشتري وتبيع الاسهم والدهب هتلاقوا
لينك ليهم تحت الفيديو وفي تعليقات فيسبوك
في ايام الاولى لظهور التليفونات المحموله
كان في حلم واحد بس مسيطر على شركات
التقنيه الكبرى وهو بناء شبكه اتصالات
ونقل معلومات تقدر تشتغل في اي مكان في
الكوكب انترنت الاقمار الصناعيه نفسه مش
اختراع جديد وانما بيستخدم من منتصف
التسعينات لكن الاقمار الخاصه به بعيده عن
الارض علشان تغطي مساحات جغ اوسع وده
معناه سرعه اقل بكتير من المطلوب مع
احتمالات انقطاعه وتاخير اعلى علشان كده
الحلم ده هيتحقق عن طريق شبكه الاقمار
الصناعيه الصغيره القريبه من الارض واللي
هي تقنيه فائقه بتمتلكها حاليا بشكل اساسي
امريكا والصين وعلشان تكونوا عارفين بس
سوق انترنت الفضاء ده متوقع توصل قيمته
خلال اقل من 20 سنه ل 412 مليار دولار
يعني قرابه نص تريليون دولار ده حجم
التورته اللي بيتم الصراع عليها دلوقتي بس
خلونا نفهم الاول استار لينك دي زي ما
قلنا في المقدمه ستار لينك هو مشروع اساسه
مجموعه ضخمه من الاقمار الصناعيه الصغيره
واللي وزنها خفيف هتديرها سبيس اكس وبتدور
على ارتفاعات قليله جدا حوالين الارض وزن
القمر الواحد بين 1500 كيلو جرام بس
مقارنه بالوزن المعتاد للاقمار الضخمه
اللي بتكون ما بين خمسه وسته طن للقمر
الواحد و ستار لينك بتستخدم ليزر
للاشارات بينها وده بيخليها تحتاج لمحطات
ارضيه اقل زائد ان دورانها على ارتفاع
قليل هيتيح لها حريه حركه اوسع وبالتالي
زياده سرعه الانترنت وتقليلا قطاعات اول
ستين قمر اطلقوا في مايو 2019 وكانوا شبه
قطر مضيء في السماء زي ما انتم شايفين
قدامكم كده من الوقت ده لحد الشهر اللي
فات مايو 2023 حصل التطورات ضخمه في
المشروع ده وخلونا نبص فيها بسرعه عدد
اقمار ستار لينك اللي في مداراتها وصل
حاليا لاربع الاف امر بتوفر الوصول السهل
الانترنت في 53 دوله والخطه ان العدد يوصل
ل 12 الف قمر في 2030 وحوالي 42,000 في
المستقبل القريب وده 15 مره ضعف عدد
الاقمار الصناعيه الموجوده حاليا في
الفضاء لكل دول العالم مجتمعه وفي مايو
برضو وصل عدد مستخدمي الشبكه لمليون ونص
مشترك وبتستهدف الشركه مع البدء في 2025
يكون 40 مليون مشترك مع ارباح قدرتها
مبدئيا ب 30 مليار دولار طب امتى اثبتت
ستار لينك قدرتها والصين بدات تلتفت
للتهديد ده بشكل اكثر جديه الحقيقه هي ان
الصين واخده بالها من التهديد ومنخرطه في
سباق فضاء ضد امريكا من سنين طويله زي ما
هنوضح بعد شويه لكن المحك الحقيقي كان
الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا لحد قبل الغزو
بايام كانت بتضغط من شهور طويله علشان
تاخد تصريح بالعمل في اوكرانيا وما كانوش
خدوه لحد ما روسيا بدات الغزو وبعد يومين
بالضبط من بدء الغزو الروسي وزير التحول
الرقم الاوكراني ميخائيله جري على ايلون
ماسك وغرض بتويتا منشنوا فيها وطلب منه
بشكل مباشر انه يدعم اوكرانيا بستار لينك
والنظام الاوكراني الضوء الاخضر للعمل على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه وقد كان شركه سبيس اكس
بعتت 20 الف وحده انترنت مجانيه من اللينك
للاوكرانيين والى الماسك ساعتها حول
اوكرانيا كلها لساحه اختبار فريده من
نوعها ومهمه للانترنت المستقبلي بتاعه في
خدام عوامل ينظر انها تتجمع مع بعض او
يلاقي فرصه زي دي يختبر مشروعه من خلالها
عوامل زي انقطاع الكهرباء والعمليات
العسكريه العنيفه والدمار اللي جاي معها
والتشويش الالكتروني الروسي على الانظمه
الاوكرانيه باعتراف الجنريلات الاوكرانيين
نفسهم فلولا شبكه ستارلينج كانت اوكرانيا
خسرت الحرب في ايامها الاولى مباشره وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني
ووصف الشبكه بانها حاسمه وفعاله الوضع
استمر بالشكل ده لحد اكتوبر 2022 ساعتها
ايلون ماسك بدا يشتكي من تحمله لتكلفه
تشغيلهم هناك وكان على وشك يشد الفيشه لو
الاوكرانيين ما دفعوش وبعد ضغوط رسميه
امريكيه اعلن استمراره في تحمل تكلفه
تشغيل ستارلينج استمر كده لحد فبراير اللي
فات ده لما سبيس اكس اعلنت تقييد وصول
اوكرانيا علشان الجيش الاوكراني بيستخدم
الشبكه في عمليات عسكريه زي توجيه هجمات
بطائرات بدون طيار على القوات الروسيه كل
ده ياخدنا لاهم محاور حلقتنا النهارده وهي
الصيام قبل ما اشرح لكم ازاي الصينيين
شايفين مشروع ستار لينك تهديد امريكا
حقيقي لهم لازم نتكلم الاول عن طموحات
الصين الفضائيه وليه وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه
بتعتبر الصين هي التهديد العالمي الاكبر
لها في الفضاء
ركزوا معي كويس جدا في اللي جاي ده
الحقيقه ان صناعه الفضاء الصينيه بتتطور
بشكل سريع من بعد ما فتحت بكين المجال
للقطاع الخاص الصيني سنه 2014 ورغم ان
الشركات المملوكه للدوله لسه بتهيمن على
القطاع ده الا انه مثلا شركه اوربيتال جيت
كورسيو للاستشارات ومقرها فون كونج بتقول
ان في حاليا حوالي 20 شركه اطلاق مكو
التجاريه او خاصه في الصيام في محطات مهمه
وعلامات في مشوار صناعه الفضاء الصينيه زي
ان الصين هي اول دوله تهبط بمركبه روفر
على الجانب البعيد من القمر سنه 2019 وزي
انها حاليا بتمتلك محطه فضاء خاصه بها
اسمها
اطلقتها سنه 2021 وزي انها بتهدف لاعاده
اول عينات تربه خاصه بها من المريخ على
سنه 2030 اجمالا وفي اخر عشر سنين تحديدا
هنلاقي ان الصين استثمرت بكثافه في
برنامجها الفضائي وطورت الصواريخ الارضيه
والليزر ورفعت قدرات المراقبه الفضائيه
عندها كل ده جزء من اهدافها العسكريه
الاوسع اللي بتتلخص في حرمان خصومها من
الوصول للوصول الموجوده في الفضاء نفس
مدرسه امريكا يعني بياكد الكلام ده
التقييم السنوي للتهديدات للسنه الحاليه
الصادر عن مجتمع الاستخبارات الامريكيه من
ثلاث شهور واللي قال نصا ان الصين بتتقدم
نحو هدفها في انها تبقى رائده فضاء عالميه
لمواكبه الولايات المتحده او تجاوزها على
سنه 2045 لكن احنا مش هنتكلم على كل
مجالات الفضاء الصينيه وانما يهمنا
التركيز على تطور مساحه الاقمار الصناعيه
هناك وعلاقه ستار لينك بها لو بصينا
هنلاقي انه في ابريل 2020 تحول انترنت
الاقمار الصناعيه لاولويه الصينيه وطنيه
رسميه وده حصل لما اكبر وكاله للتخطيط
الاقتصادي في البلد اللي هي اللجنه
الصينيه الوطنيه للتنميه والاصلاح
والمعروفه اختصارا بان دي ار سي ادرجته في
قائمه رغبات البنيه التحتيه الجديده وفي
ديسمبر اللي فات صدر تقرير عن مركز
الدراسات الاستراتيجيه والدوليه الامريكي
قال ان الصين محتمل جدا تخلي اتصالات
الاقمار الصناعيه ضمن برنامجها للبنيه
التحتيه اللي قيمه تريليون دولار وهو
مبادره الحزام والطريق وتسوقوا لدول
بتعتمد في بنيتها
ممكن تخليك تقدر تحمل واحد تيرا بايت او
الف جيجا في ثانيه واحده بس اجمالا في
الصين حاليا ما يزيد عن سبع شركات حكوميه
وخاصه بتبني مصانع وبتطور بنيه تحتيه
علشان البلد تقدر تنتج قريب جدا مئات
الاقمار الصناعيه الصغيره سنويا زي سبيس
اكس كده من ضمن الشركات دي شركه بيجين
ودي شركه خاصه بتحاول تطور صواريخ حديثه
تقدر تشيل وتنشر حوالي 60 قمر صناعي في
الرحله الواحده ودي تقريبا نفس حموله
صاروخ فالكون 9 القابل لاعاده الاستخدام
واللي بتستخدمه سبيس اكس لنشر اقمار ستار
لينك واللي ساهم في النمو السريع لسبيس
اكس بفضل التكاليفه المنخفضه وسعه حمولته
الكبيره علشان كده في ابريل اللي فات
الشركه الصينيه خدت خطوه مهمه لما اطلقت
صاروخ بيشتغل بالوقود السائل لاول مره على
غرار صواريخ فعلكم والاطلاق ده بياكد وجهه
نظ
رئيسه نفسها اللي قالت ان الصينيين
مشكلتهم الاكبر هي عدم امتلاكهم لصواريخ
متطوره لكن قريب هيمتلكوها ليه الخطوه دي
مهمه جدا للصينيين هقول لكم لو بصينا على
عدد الاقمار الصناعيه اللي اطلقته الصين
السنه اللي فاتت 2022 هنلاقيه 182 قمر
صناعي ده يبدو رقم كبير لاي دوله في
العالم ويخلي الصين تستمر في يكونها القوه
الفضائيه التانيه عالميه لكن بالنسبه
للمنافس الرئيسي اللي هي الولايات المتحده
فده اقل من عشر عدد الاقمار الامريكيه
الجديده في نفس السنه دي بس طب ليه الفرق
المهول ده لان طموح بكين لبناء شبكه
انترنت عبر الاقمار الصناعيه بيواجه شويه
عقبات مش سهله اهمها قدره الاطلاق
المحدوده يعني ما فيش عند الصينيين حتى
الان شركه صواريخ كامله مثلا بتخدم على
المشروع زي سبيس اكس اللي له الماسك بناها
في اكتر من 20 سنه
علشان حضراتكم تستوعبوا سبيس اكس نموذج
فريد جدا في عالم الفضاء والشركات عموما
لانها ماسكه سلسله التوريد من اولها
لاخرها من اول ابتكار التقنيه وتصميمها
سواء الصواريخ او الاقمار وغيرها مرورا
بالتصنيع وصولا للاطلاق من منصتها الخاصه
وليس انتهاء بالصيانه والمتابعه الدوريه
والتطوير فالحاله الكامله دي لسه صعبه على
الصينيين يوصلوا لها حاليا او في المستقبل
قريب وعلى اي دوله تانيه في العالم العقبه
التانيه قدام الصينيين هي الحواجز
التكنولوجيه في فرق تقني واسع بين
المنتجات الصينيه والامريكيه في الدقه
والكفاءه والجوده والتاثير وده برده
الصينيين بيسعوا يتغلبوا عليه في العقود
الجايه لكن قدره ستار لينك على انها توفر
للاوكرانيين اتصالات مستقره وانترنت عالي
السرعه على الرغم من تدمير الروس للبنيه
التحتيه للاتصالات ملكيه واللاسيه اكدت
للصينيين ان ده المستقبل وانهم محتاجين
اساطير مماثله من الاقمار الصناعيه دي
والمعروفه باسم الابراج
بس قبل ما نتكلم عن ليل النموذج الاوكراني
مخوف الصين جدا خلينا نوضح بسرعه انه مش
الصين لوحدها اللي بتسعى تكون اساطرها
الخاصه من الاقمار الصناعيه وان السوق ده
اللي هيوصل حجمه لنص تريليون دولار السنين
الجايه الحكومات والشركات بيقطعوا بعض
عليها طبعا امريكا هي رائده المساحه دي
يعني على المستوى العسكري هنلاقي ان في
فرقه في القوه الفضائيه الامريكيه شغاله
على تكوين اسطول اقمار عسكريه صغيره خاص
بها الاسطول ده هينضم لحوالي 350 قمر
صناعي عسكري امريكي حالي من مختلف الانواع
بيستخدمه لتعقب ومراقبه مساعده القوات
الامريكيه في العالم على مدار العشر سنين
اللي فاتوا البنتاجون بقى بيعتمد جدا على
قطاع الفضاء التجاري وبيستخدم صواريخ سبيس
اكس تحديدا علشان ينشر اقمار صناعيه
دفاعيه سريه وده يوصلنا لمشروع ايلون ماسك
جديد ستارشيلد ده مشروع اعلنت عنه
2022 وهيكون موجه ناحيه اعراض الامن
القومي للحكومات بس والصينيين خايفين انه
ممكن يكشف سريه البرامج العسكريه الصناعيه
وبيوصفوه انه هيبقى كان الامريكيين
هيركبوا كاميرات مراقبه في كل انحاء
العالم على المستوى التجاري يكفي نعرف ان
لجنه الاتصالات الفيدراليه
بتحاول تهندل الاقبال الضخم على اطلاق
الاقمار الصناعيه وقدامها حاليا طلبات من
وكالات وشركات متعدده لاطلاق اكتر من 64
الف امر صناعي جديد خاصه من منافسين سبيس
اكس زي امازون كايبر وفياسات وديش لو
بصينا على اوروبا هنلاقي ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي بيبني حاليا اسطوله برده زي شركه
ريفاده الالمانيه اللي هتطلق اقمارها
الخاصه قريب لكن الاسطول الاوروبي الاقوى
والاوضح اتكون لما شركه الاتصالات
الفرنسيه
اتمت صفقه استحواذ على شركه
البريطانيه اللي قيمتها 3.4 مليار دولار
في منتصف 2022 علشان اسطولين الشركه من
الاقمار الصناعيه ينضموا على بعض ويبقوا
اسطول واحد عدد اقمار الصناعيه
464 قمر فهتكون له فرص افضل واعلى في
منافسه ستارلينج والصينيين في المستقبل
لكن يظل البعبع الحقيقي بالنسبه للصين هو
شبكه الصينيين بيمتلكوا تخوفين كبار الاول
هو ايه اللي هيحصل لو صحيوا الصبح وقرروا
غزو تايوان لينك ساعد النظام التايواني زي
ما حصل مع اوكرانيا والتاني هو ان امريكا
عن طريق ستار لينك تحديدا
تشرب حاليا مساحات المدار الارض المنخفض
من الصين اللي طموحها انها تكون قوه هائله
في سوق الانترنت الفضائي مش بس السوق ولكن
في مساحه نقل البيانات بسرعه فائقه
بالنسبه للتخوف الاول فمن المؤكد انه ضمن
خطه الغزو هيكون في قطع 14 كابل بحري لنقل
الانترنت والكابلات دي بشكل اساسي هي اللي
بتربط تايوانه سكانها وشركاتها بالعالم
والحياه عموما علشان كده تايوان بتضيف
كابلات اكتر وبتخطط للدفاع عن الكابلات دي
لكن برضو بتختبر ستارلينج في 700 موقع
منها مواقع بره تايوان نفسها الصين من ضمن
الدول اللي بتعدي على صوابع الايد اللي
عندها القدره على اسقاط الاقمار الصناعيه
عن طريق ضربها بصواريخ بلاستيا لكن
المشكله ان شبكه ايلون ماسك ستارلينج
مكونه زي ما عرفنا من الاف الاقمار فده
خيار مستحيل علشان كده الصينيين شغالين
على ضبط خطه تتبنى تكنيك القتل الناعم مع
ستار لينك يعني ايه بقى يعني بدل ما نضرب
بالصواريخ ونخلق كميه هائله من الحطام في
المدار الارض المنخفض هنشتغل على تطوير
اشعه الليزر اللي تقدر تدمر او تعطل
الاقمار الصناعيه الامريكيه بدون فوضى
كبيره وصولا لتقنيات التشويش والتدخل
السيبراني الصينيين هنا واخدين صفحه من
كتاب الروس اللي كشف تقرير استخباراتي
امريكي سري للغايه في ابريل اللي فات انهم
بيختبروا من فتره نظام تشويش وافساد موجه
ضد ستارلينج ضمن انظمه الحرب الالكترونيه
الروسيه المعروفه بتوبال والتقرير ده تم
تسريبه ضمن تسريبات الوثائق الاستخباراتيه
الامريكيه الفتره الاخيره المشكله هنا ان
الصينيين نفسهم لحد اللحظه مش فاهمين عدد
من اهداف شبكه ستارلينج او امكانياتها
الكامله واللي هي بالضروره معلومات ما
يعرفهاش غير وبعد مسؤول سبيس اكس
والبنتاجون وبعض العاملين على الشبكه
نفسها لكن التهديد الصيني بالاكل الناعم
بياكدوا جنرال تشانس رئيس العمليات
الفضائيه لقوه الفضاء الامريكيه واللي قال
في جلسه استماع في الكونجرس في مارس اللي
فات ان الصين بتختبر حاليا نظام اقمار
صناعيه يمكن تسليح وقت الحروق وان بكين
اظهرت قدرتها على التحكم فيه وتحريك اقمار
صناعيه تانيه وقال نصا ان اي شيء بنعمله
في الفضاء ما لوش اي لازمه طالما شبكاتنا
المعلوماتيه معرضه للهجوم علشان كده
الحزمه الجايه من الصواريخ اللي هتروح
للقوه الفضائيه الامريكيه هتركز على قدره
الصواريخ دي على ضرب وتدمير اي تهديد ضد
الاقمار الصناعيه وايضا الامريكيين
هيحاولوا يخلوا الاقمار الصناعيه بتاعتهم
اقل عرضه للتشويش واكتر حصانه ضد الافساد
لكن في خيار للصين هو انها غالبا هتضطر
تعتمد على ايلون ماسك نفسه في انه يحرم
تايوان من الوصول للشبكه في المستقبل
اعتمادا على ان مصالح ماسك في الصين كبيره
وعلى راسها مصنع تسلا الضغط في شنغهاي على
الجانب الاخر فهوكاله الفضاء التايوانيه
بتطور اقمرها الصناعيه الخاصه للاتصالات
للمدار المنخفض متوقع يطلقوا اول واحد في
2025 فيما يخص تخوف الصين التاني من هيمنه
الامريكيين على الفضاء القريب من الارض
فهم بينتهجوا اساليب مختلفه منها الهجوم
الاعلامي والرسمي واللي بيدعوا فيه ان
المساحه دي مش هتشيل غير خمسين الف قمر
صناعي بس وممنعها ضغط الباحثين الصينيين
في الاشهر الاخيره على الحكومه لما شاركوا
مخوفهم في الابحاث العامه واللقاءات
الخاصه مع المسؤولين العسكريين من ان
مشروع جي دبليو متاخر جدا عن ستارلينج
ولازم يتم تسريعه اجمالا والمده لن تقل عن
عشر سنين جايه امريكا هتفضل متفوقه
وهتمتلك الهيمنه الاكبر على المساحه دي في
فضل سبيس اكس والتقنيه المتطوره والموارد
غير المحدوده عند الامريكيين لحد هنا انا
خلصت كلامي وكالعاده عندي سؤال لحضراتكم
هل في دوله عربيه ممكن نشوفها قريب بتنضم
لسباق الفضاء ده ولا ده صعب نشوفه في
المستقبل قريب هتابع ارائكم كلها في
التعليقات اللي عايز يشتري اسهم او ذهب ما
تنسوش تشوفوا شركه اكسنس هتلاقوا رابط تحت
الفيديو ما تنسوش تشتركوا في القناه زي ما
اتفقنا ويا ريت لو عجبتكم الحلقه تعملوا
لايك وشير للفيديو واهم حاجه تحكوا
لاصحابكم وحبايبكم عننا يمكن استفيدوا
سلام
[موسيقى]